لا مواساه كفيله بتهدئه روع السودانيين لا
في الشوارع التي تعج بالمسلحين ولا حتى في
ملاجئ الاطفال حيث لا امان يطوقهم
الان الوضع بك صعب جدا جدا اسره خالية من
اجسادهم الغضه يتمتهم الحياه مرتين فقد
السند ثم عرف الموت طريقه الى دار
الميغوما للايتام في الخرطوم اكثر من 50
طفلا بينهم عشرون رضيعا سلبتهم الحرب
حياتهم جوعا ووهنا وخلال 24 ساعه فقدت
حياته 13 اخرين لم تتجاوز اعمارهم ربيعا
واحدا ربيعا ما كان كافيا ليقف على ارجلهم
ذاهبين الى مكانهم المفضل بين الاراجيح
[موسيقى]
بكوا لساعات حان وقت رضعتهم لكن لا حليب
يقطر في افواههم كل المنجدين عاثت بهم طرق
لا صوت يعلو فيها سوى عزيزي الرصاص فكانت
دمار اقسى من ان يؤمن لهم الغذاء وادنى
حقوق الرعايه الصحيه
هذه دعوه لمساعده انسانيه وسلام وامل
بحياه طبيعيه وافضل للايتام المحاصرين في
الخرطوم بسبب الحرب والانتهاكات انا اقف
هنا في هذا الوضع للمره الثانيه ارجوكم
هناك ما يفوق الثلاثه مئه طفل تتراوح
اعمارهم بين ايام وسنوات ينتظرون نجدتكم
يهدا القصف فيهرع الاطباء الى تلك الدور
لتكون الصدمه مشاهد اقسى من الوصف رضع وخد
دج اتوا الى الدنيا لايام وفارقوها باكفان
لفتهم قبل ان يكتبوا حلما كان قد مر في
خيالهم اسراء الصغير العربيه
[موسيقى]
الاوضاع الامنيه للبلد عمل الترادي في
القطاع الصحي الموجه
طلعت من الخدمه ان احنا في منطقه هي في
مرمى النيران
كلها يعني غيار جروح اي زول عنده علاج
عنده متوفر في البيت او زايد يوديه لناس
الطوارئ احنا هنا في الراشدين شمال بنحتاج
لكل الادويه بنحتاج للاطباء ومحتاجين لاي
زوجاته انه يساعدنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات